BE.
>> Greg: WE’RE ABOUT TO SHOW YOU
SOMETHING THAT WILL BREAK YOUR
HEART.
THIS IS DAVID DORN IN HIS LAST
MOMENTS ON EARTH.
HE’S BLEATING TO DEATH ON A
SIDEWALK FROM FRONT OF A LOOTED
SHOT.
HE’S A FORMER POLICE CAPTAIN
PROTECTING A STORE.
HIS NAME IS DAVID DORN.
HE WAS A BLACK MAN, A FAMILY
MAN, A GOOD MAN, A POLICE
CAPTAIN.
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
BUT NOT TO LOOTERS, RIOTERS AND
AGITATORS.
SHOULD WE BLAME THIS ON SYSTEMIC
RACISM?
WHO SHOT HIM?
MAKE SETH ROGEN BAILED HIM OUT
ALREADY.
HERE’S WORDS FROM HIS FAMILY.
>> THIS IS OVER TVs, STUFF THAT
IS REPLACEABLE.
THEY’RE FORGETTING THE REAL
MESSAGE FOR THE PROTESTS AND THE
POSITIVENESS THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
COME OUT OF IT.
WE GET THIS NEGATIVE LIGHT SHOWN
ON A SITUATION THAT NEEDED LIGHT
TO BE BROUGHT TO IT.
>> I HOPE THAT THE PERSON THAT
DID THIS, THAT THEY COME FORTH
OR WHATEVER.
BECAUSE THIS IS JUST SO
SENSELESS.
I’M TIRED OF IT.
I’M JUST TIRED.
>> THE FACT IS, REDEFINING BLOOD
LUST AS JUSTIFIED LEADS TO
DEATH.
NOT JUST MR. DORN BUT A
COUNTRY’S, TOO.
YESTERDAY WAS BLACK-OUT TUESDAY
WHERE INSTAGRAMERS SET THEIR
BACKGROUND TO BLACK TO SUPPORT
THE PROTESTS.
THE MEDIA BLACKS OUT THE
VIOLENCE TO HIDE THEIR
CULPABILITY
CULPABILITY.
MAYBE MR. DORN’S DEATH CAN
CHANGE THINGS.
MAYBE WE CAN PROTEST LOUDLY IN
HIS NAME AND LOUDLY DEMAND
ACTION.
IT’S TIME.
THERE’S NO SUPERMAN COMING TO
SAVE THE DAY FOR US.
THERE’S NO ONE BUT US.
TO QUOTE A CNN ANCHOR, WHO SAYS
PROTESTS NEED TO BE PEACEFUL?
>> PLEASE, SHOW ME WHERE IT SAYS
THAT PROTESTS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
POLITE AND PEACEFUL?
I CAN SHOW YOU THAT OUTRAGE
CITIZENS ARE THE ONES THAT MADE
AMERICA WHAT SHE IS AND LED TO
ANY MAJOR MILESTONE.
BE HONEST, THIS IS NOT A
TRANQUIL TIME.
>> Greg: NO THANKS TO YOU.
AS CITIES ARE RAVAGED, HE SAYS
PROTESTS DON’T HAVE TO BE
PEACEFUL.
CHRIS, INVITE YOU TO MEET ME IN
ME NEIGHBORHOOD TO SEE WHAT
OUTRAGE CREATED.
THE DEAD-EYE LOOKED FROM PEOPLE
TRYING TO SALVAGE WHAT IS LEFT
OF THEIR LIVES.
IF ONLY THEY COULD WORK IN MEDIA
AND SEE THE SILVER LINING.
THIS IS NOT A TRANQUIL TIME.
THANKS FOR THE HONESTY, CHRIS.
YOU KNOW, SWAN -- THERE’S SO
MANY DISTURBING PARTS TO THIS.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A BLACK MAN
WHO PROBABLY HELPED ME PEOPLE IN
BLACK COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE MURDERED BY A LOOTER AND
THEY FILMED IT.
YOU DIDN’T SEE ANYBODY HELPING
HIM.
YOU JUST SAW HIS BODY BLEEDING
OUT AND PEOPLE FILMING IT.
>> Juan: YEAH, IT’S HORRIFIC.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S ANYTHING
TO SAY BUT THAT THIS IS A HORROR
SHOW.
YOU KNOW, THE IDEA OF THE SOCIAL
MEDIA AND EVEN I THINK SOMEBODY
WAS SAYING HANG IN THERE, YOU
KNOW, LIKE OH, GEE, LIKE SOMEONE
WAS TRYING.
BUT TO ME, I WAS GLAD IT WAS
REMOVED BECAUSE IT’S A HUMAN
BEING.
SO THE PEOPLE THAT DID THIS,
GREG, SHOULD BE PROSECUTED TO
THE FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW AS
CRIMINALS.
HAVING TAKEN A GOOD MAN’S LIFE.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S ANYWAY TO
GET AROUND THAT.
NOW, LET ME SAY, I DO HAVE
ANOTHER VIEWPOINT ON THIS, WHICH
IS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE’RE
DISCUSSING HIS DEATH BUT YOU
KNOW, WE DIDN’T DISCUSS
SOMETHING LIKE BREANNA TAYLOR,
THE WOMAN THAT WAS 26 YEARS OLD,
SHOT EIGHT TIMES IN HER BED AS
POLICE EXECUTE A NO-KNOCK
WARRANT AND RUSH INTO HER HOUSE.
TURNED OUT TO BE THE WRONG HOLD.
KILLED THIS 26-YEAR-OLD IN HER
BED.
WE DON’T TALK ABOUT IT.
FOR LOTS OF PEOPLE, THIS, AS TO
SELECTIVE MORALE OUTRAGE.
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY PICKS A CASE
AND SAYS, I WANT TO LOOK AT THAT
ONE.
WHY HAVEN’T WE SEEN MORE
DISCUSSION OF BREANNA TAYLOR?
IT TOOK TWO MONTHS TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION OF THE GEORGIA JOGGER
AND IF IT WASN’T FOR THE VIDEO,
THAT CASE MIGHT HAVE BEEN SWEPT
UNDER THE REGULAR.
SO YOU SEE A LOT OF PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATORS.
FOR THE MOST PART, THEY ARE THE
STORY HERE.
THERE’S LOOTERS, VANDALS, THOSE
PEOPLE THAT KILLED A MAN IN
ST. LOUIS.
FOR MOST PEOPLE, IT’S A SENSE OF
FRUSTRATION OF WHAT DOES IT TAKE
TO GET JUSTICE?
DO YOU HAVE TO HAVE A VIDEO
BEFORE SOMEBODY BELIEVES YOU?
INTERNATIONAL PROTESTS TO GET
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE, BLACK
PEOPLE ARE BEING TREATED IN AN
UNJUST MANNER?
>> Greg: I CAN’T BELIEVE YOU
SAID THAT AS WE HAVE SPENT OVER
TEN DAYS OR SO TALKING ABOUT
MR. FLOYD AND EVERYBODY IS IN
AGREEMENT ABOUT THE HORRENDOUS
DEATH.
WE HAVE COVERED THESE INJUSTICES
REGULARLY.
THERE WAS AN ELDERLY COUPLE,
JUAN, THAT WAS EXECUTED AT A
VETERAN’S CEMETERY BY A MAN THAT
DIED IN A FOREST.
NOBODY DARED COVER THAT.
AN ELDERLY COVER VISITING THEIR
SON AT A CEMETERY.
WE CAN SIT HERE AND TAKE THIS
STORY AND SHIFT IT INTO A TIT
FOR TAT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT INJUSTICE.
IT’S ABOUT A MAN’S DEATH.
ALL RIGHT.
>> Juan: I’M AGREEING WITH YOU.
>> Greg: LET ME MOVE ON, OKAY?
I WANT TO GET OTHER PEOPLE IN.
DANA, I DIDN’T SEE THIS STORY
ANYWHERE ON THE OTHER NETWORKS
BUT ONLINE.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
YOU THINK ISN’T IMPORTANT TO
THEM?
>> Dana: WELL, I DON’T KNOW WHAT
IS IN THEIR MINDS.
WHATEVER ENDS UP ON THE FRONT
PAGE OR WHATEVER ENDS UP ON AIR
IS AN EDITORIAL DECISION.
SOMEBODY IS MAKING THAT DECISION
AND DECIDING THERE’S SO MUCH
NEWS TO COVER.
THEY’RE SAYING THIS NEWS IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO US.
WE’RE ALL DRINKING FROM A
FIREHOUSE, A LOT OF NEWS OUT
THERE.
TWO POINTS I’D LIKE TO MAKE.
ONE THE FACT THAT THERE WERE NOT
POLICE OUT ANT ABOUT TO PROTECT
INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM THESE
LOOTERS, THE RIOTERS, THE
ARSONISTS, THE PEOPLE THAT
COMMIT THIS VIOLENCE.
THAT IS A HORRIBLE THING.
MR. DORN SERVED HIS COMMUNITY.
HE PAID HIS TAXES.
77 YEARS OLD.
TALK ABOUT HEART BREAK AND
LISTENING TO HIS DAUGHTER-IN-LAW
BEGGING FOR JUSTICE AND SAYING
SHE’S EXHAUSTED.
WE CAN RELATE TO THAT.
I WANTED TO POINT OUT ONE OTHER
THING.
IT WAS DEVASTATING TO SEE
THERE’S GO FUND ME ACCOUNTS FOR
LOTS OF PEOPLE.
SO DAVID DORN HAS ONE.
DAVID UNDERWOOD, KILLED IN
LOS ANGELES.
THEY’RE AROUND $50,000 OR SO,
RIGHT IN THE MINNEAPOLIS FREEDOM
FUND IS $20 MILLION.
THIS IS DRIVEN BY CELEBRITIES.
THAT IS A BAIL FUND THAT DOES
NOT DISTINGUISH BETWEEN PEOPLE
WHO ARE ARRESTED FOR PROTESTING
AND PEOPLE THAT WERE ARRESTED
FOR BIGGER CRIMES LIKE LOOTING
AND VANDALISM.
SO CELEBRITIES ARE BAILING OUT
THEFT.
FINE.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
WHAT DOES IT SAY AS A SOCIETY?
THAT THESE MEN ARE NOT BEING
SUPPORTED AS WELL AND THEIR
FAMILY.
>> Greg: YEAH, JESSE, YOU THINK
THAT CNN HAS A PROBLEM SHOWING
STUFF LIKE THIS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE DEFENDED ANTIFA?
THEY SAY NONVIOLENT PROTEST.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT?
SO WHEN THEY CAN’T SHOW THE
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE THEY’RE
CULPABLE.
>> YEAH, IT’S LIKE HIDING
EVIDENCE.
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
DO THEY MATTER LESS WHEN THAT
BLACK MAN TAKES THAT LIFE OR DO
THEY MATTER MORE WHEN A WHITE
PERSON TAKES THAT LIFE?
NO.
BLACK -- ALL BLACK LIVES MATTER
EQUALLY NO MATTER WHO TAKES IT.
YET WE ONLY SEE THIS NATIONWIDE
OUTRAGE WHEN THERE’S AN INCIDENT
OF A WHITE PERSON TAKING THE
LIFE OF A BLACK MAN.
THAT IS DONE.
YOU’VE TALKED ABOUT IT, WE’VE
TALKED ABOUT IT BY THE DEMOCRAT
MEDIA, CORPORATE POWER STRUCTURE
AND THEY DO THAT TO DIVIDE, DO
IT FOR PROFIT, THEY DO IT TO
DISTRACT TO PUT THEIR HANDS IN
PEOPLE’S POCKETS AND KEEP THEIR
POSITIONS OF POWER.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT SAY LAST
WEEK?
WHEN THE LOOTING STARTS THE
SHOOTING STARTS.
THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
THAT.
THE MAYOR OF ST. LOUIS, NOT
TOTALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS,
THE LOOTERS THAT DID THIS THIS
GUY ARE, BUT SHE DIDN’T PROTECT
THE COMMUNITY FROM THESE LOOTERS
AND THAT’S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THERE’S LOOTING.
THERE’S DEATH.
THAT’S ON HER TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT.
>> Greg: LAST WORD TO YOU,
LAWRENCE.
I’M SURE -- GO AHEAD.
>> Lawrence: IT’S DEVASTATING.
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE THERE’S NOW
BECOME THIS COMPETITION FOR WHAT
LIFE MATTERS THE MOST.
CAN WE LIKE ALL STAND UP FOR
LIFE?
JUST SAY PEOPLE THAT ARE
INNOCENT THAT ARE KILLED, WE
STAND WITH THE FAMILIES, THAT WE
WANT TO GO AFTER THE BAD GUYS
THAT DO IT?
I’M AFRAID BECAUSE THIS REMIND
ME BACK IN JULY 7, 2016.
FIVE COPS WERE SHOT.
THE GUY THAT ASSASSINATED THEM,
I HAD AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH THE FAMILY.
THE FAMILY SAID THAT HE WAS
UPSET ABOUT A TRAFFIC STOP.
HE TRIED TO DO VIGILANTE
JUSTICE.
HE KILLED FIVE COPS.
THE FIVE COPS WERE COMMUNITY
POLICE THAT PEOPLE LOVED AND
RESPECTED IN THE COMMUNITY.
YOU WENT OUT THERE AND YOU SHOT
THEM.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN CHAOS
HAPPENS.
I’M AFRAID THAT AMERICA IS ON
FIRE RIGHT NOW.
I LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
BUT I WANT EQUAL JUSTICE AND WE
SHOULD ALL BE OUTRAGED WHEN AN
INNOCENT AMERICAN, SOMEONE THAT
WEARS BLUE OR SOMEONE WITH A
HOODIE ON OR SOMEONE FROM A